what is the slope of the line that
contains the point seven has negative 19
fourths and negative two-thirds 57 8. so
i will do this problem because those the
the people who wrote this problem want
us to do it this way by using the
formula but you know i am not a fan of
blindly using formulas so maybe after we
do this we will work it out or we'll
visualize a little bit to show us that
the formula really is just measuring the
inclination of the line
so if i have two points so let's say one
point is x1
y1 and that the other point is
is x2
y2 the slope of a line and they use the
letter m for the slope of the line is
going to be the difference between the
y's and you want to make sure you get
the order right so if we start with y2
if you view y2 as the endpoint it's
going to be y2
minus y1 and once again if you started
with y2 you're gonna have to start with
x2 in the denominator we started with y2
in the numerator we're going to start
with x2 in the denominator it's going to
be x2
minus
minus x1 so that's the slope between
these two points so if we pick this to
be x1 y1 so let's do that let's say that
this one right over here is x1
and y1 in which case x1 itself will be
equal to 7 halves and y1 will be equal
to negative 19 over 4
right all i did is i set this is x1 y1
and if we set this over here to be x2
y2 then we know that x2 is going to be
equal to negative two-thirds and that y2
is going to be equal to 57
57 over 8. and then we essentially can
just apply what we know about the slope
the slope between those two points is
going to be equal to y2
which is 57 over 8 57 over 8
minus y1 which is 19 over 4
minus which is 19 over 4. all of that
over
x2
x2 is negative two-thirds negative
two-thirds
minus
minus x-one which is seven
which is seven halves and now frankly
the hardest part of actually doing this
is to is to deal with the fractions over
here
so let's
let's multiply there's a bunch of ways
that we could actually think about doing
it we could multiply
we could multiply well let me just do it
let me just do it straight up so a
common denominator over here would be
eight
would be eight so this is 57 over eight
let me do that same color
so we don't get our
math mixed up 57 over eight and then if
i were to write 19 over 4 with a
denominator of 8 i multiplied 4 times 2
to get 8 so i have to multiply 19 times
2 so i get 38 and then that's going to
be over
a common denominator over here is going
to be 6.
that's their least common multiple so
negative two-thirds is the same thing as
negative four six three times two is six
negative two times two is negative four
and then negative seven halves over six
if i write it with a denominator of six
two times 3 is 6
so 7 times 3 is 21
and so now i can simplify this numerator
right over here is going to be equal to
let's see 57 minus 37 would be 20
so this is going to be
one less than that because i'm
subtracting 38 so it's going to be
negative 19
negative 19 or sorry positive 19
positive 19 57 is clearly greater than
38
so 57 minus so it's 19 over 8
over
i'll do this in pink
negative 4
minus 21 over 6 gives us negative
25
negative 25 over 6. and so i have 19
over 8 divided by negative 25 over 6.
when you divide by a fraction so 19 this
is the same thing as multiplying as
multiplying by its reciprocal
multiplying by negative 6 over
25 and let's see we can do some
simplification right over here in the
numerator and the denominator are both
divisible by two so let's divide them
both by two this becomes a three
this becomes a four and we are left with
we are left with 19
times three
19 times three is going to be 3 less
than 20 times 3 so it's going to be 57
you have 30 plus 27 so it's going to be
57 let me write it over here actually
it's going to be equal to 57
over 4 times 25 that's pretty
straightforward 4 times 25 is just
is just 100 so we get a slope of
we get a slope of 57 oh i want to be
careful i have that negative sign there
and i almost overwrote it when i
have this negative sign right over here
so let me be very clear 19 times
negative 3
is going to be negative 57 and then 4
times 25 is 100
so our slope is negative 57 over 100 and
that's about how much we can simplify it
and we are done and i encourage you if
you have time so that you get a sense
for why this is working out plot these
two points on uh on a on on on a
coordinate plane and you'll see that
this thing right over here y2 minus y1
that really is just your change in y and
you'll see that the x2 minus x1 really
is just your change in x and i also
encourage you
take this point as x1 y1 and take this
one as x2 y2 and you'll see that you'll
still get the same result as long as
over here we took we in the numerator we
took this guy minus this guy in the
denominator this guy minus that guy if
we did it the other way around in the
numerator you would have this guy minus
that guy and then the denominator this
guy minus this guy the key is whichever
one you picked first you have to pick
the first one you have to pick it
in the numerator and denominator you
have to pick it from the same coordinate
so these both came from the same
coordinate these both came from the same
coordinates so i encourage you to swap
these around and you should get the same
result